[Laughter]
that is wild I am so glad I found this
topic this is opening my eyes that's
crazy y cuz I've no places where people
think like that but they're never this
open no cheating is considered normal
things and very common things to do in
Japanese dating culture and also
marriage
culture especially for marriage couple
cheating is so common that I almost want
to puke for example going to
prostitutions is okay things to do even
though you're in a relationship a lot of
Japanese men going to prostitution place
with their coworker or their Voss after
their
work with company money I know it sounds
really [__] up but it's super [__]
common and everybody do that what do you
think happy
hour
wild so this is I didn't know if this is
true I was curious I started doing some
Googles why do 84% of Japanese women
think cheating is
healthy you probably heard The Whispers
of Japanese hookup bars before typically
guarded by external incom and
walkie-talkie wielding staff strict
anonymity policies are commonplace in
back room hookups are encouraged the
anonymity of These Bars appeals to
people looking for uncomplicated
stress-free hookups but it's not
uncommon for patrons to eventually
discover sometimes after multiple
Rendevous that their back room
acquaintance is married
half of the patrons generally
are which explains the scent-free soap
in the
showers
dou cheating is very much normalized in
Japan which I always thought was really
really weird you can't cheat on a wife
but if you have a girlfriend it's okay
to cheat why do you think Japanese
people do that this idea of getting into
relationships is just so strongly pushed
down your throat a lot of people just
want the status of being in a
relationship but aren't for the most
part committed to it so thoughts
thoughts on the fact I think it makes
sense especially when you have like
repressive uh cultures and societies
like
that uh or whenever they push down
certain things down your throat there's
something when you push something down
the throat of someone pun intended
something else is going to come out guys
hi there I'm Takashi from Japan so today
I'm going to interview Japanese guys why
it's normal for them to cheat on G every
freshing Fan's ears just perked up say
again huh where am I supposed to go
cheating don't you mean exercising
options listen as a low value man who
donates the fresh and fit regularly my
opinion is that if I want to use my
hard-earned Super Chat money now that
they're demonetized on hookers I should
be able
to sorry let's keep
watching
he saw Qui people one yes but could it
be
[Music]
me
he said yep he said not yet is that not
yet yo that is a wild
culture fire I haven't
yet
okay
prti yo I I am so glad glad I found this
topic this is opening my eyes that's
crazy yo cuz I've know places where
people think like that but they're never
this open about no right like I know
trust me there's a lot of societies
where cheating is rampant rampant
everybody cheating yes they are you know
it too where your mama she your mama but
your dad I don't know they cheating
[__] your mama is your mama but your
daddy I don't know yeah you heard what I
said [__]
you stupid you know what I mean y know
you know what I your mom that I don't
know I'm just saying your mom on your
daddy how do you like the guy in the
middle huh how do you like the guy in
the middle I mean he's straightforward
yeah you don't feel any better about him
now that he's got like a t-shirt with
you on
it hey yo preach you wild it right now
on this
t-shirt
that is wild and and [__] that is
wild and
[__] the prostitution thing isn't
that surprising I've heard a lot of
women say that okay and the logic behind
it is women want to know that they have
that emotional connection with you and
that their place is not threatened in
terms of like them being your wife I a
show question that people ask when their
partner cheat on them yeah do you love
them what you know if it's like a a
prostitute it's obviously still a
betrayal but it feels like less of a
betrayal for some women and it like it
tracks on it makes sense
why uh
oh you see I was waiting for that and
the guy is like same same I don't care
I'm not mad at
that it is what it is well it's
actually cuz I wouldn't understand how
he would be making a logic like The
Logical point of being like no no if
it's her it's it's bad no because
there's a lot of male Idols in in Japan
or you know people who male hosts Whose
job is to sleep with married women or
women who are coming who are single
right the thing
is marriage often times in the Western
World it seems like a union of love and
this and that but for some other parts
of the world like it is far more status
and business than it is anything else
and so in a union where there's no kind
of love or lust for each other but
sometimes both of the parties end up
using these host services to fulfill
their desires or their carnal stuff and
then they have their husband or their
wives for the more family presentable
outside stuff so that's the gist of it I
mean some of that even exists here in
North America but far less than other
places
yeah cuz everybody talk about Girls Just
Want to Have Fun what about the boys
let's hear it for the
boys and on that day nobody believed
you
we'll find out see what the Japanese do
you think do you think do you think uh
do you think prostitution is uh cheating
nigeritis that's what it sound like
they's
saying
yes
[Laughter]
for you know what the thing is traveling
like
that there a lot of things sometimes
when you travel and you
confront other people when you talk to
other people you're confronted with all
these different realities and it really
confronts what you think and your your
your values it's just like little thing
when I was in Russia I was talking to
the people there
and when I was talking to some the
people and it I was introduced to other
people they was
say my name is
this and I would they just say like hey
my name is Natasha or my name is this
and that they wouldn't follow up know
usually we go hey what's up I'm preach
how you
doing they don't ask how you doing
because I don't know you enough to care
I'm not going to ask hey on the first
time that we met we meet hey my name is
my name is is is what if there is a
bunch of Russians watching right now
like yo preach lying I ask everybody how
they doing why why why why preach making
us seem like like cold Vladimir Putin
cyborgs but well it's just different
it's not that they cold I think there's
a different logic and I I I enjoy the
logic over there like I'm not going to
say how you doing I don't know you like
that so you wish you were Russian no but
I understand that part it sometimes it
makes you it makes you like why do I ask
people how they doing I don't I don't
really care on the first time it's true
pleased to meet you am I okay so Howes
how does this relate to this well
whenever you go there when you go there
when you go to like Japan and this is a
different logic and it it shakes your
logic that you have that you think it's
is the only thing that should be but
then again okay what if the relationship
to emotion and the the relationship to
feelings is just different if if it's
Spade it's no feelings it's the feelings
that we care about the same way that
that most of the people here care about
the feelings did you have no feelings
for her no it's just a girl it's nothing
so they translate it differently if you
paid i' rather you pay then you go off
it's going to happen it's like they
accept that it's going to happen it's
like at least pay for it if you pay for
it I know it's it's not real it's not a
real thing yeah I think go ahead am I
for it not necessarily but it makes you
ask a question go ahead yeah I think it
is the part of like nature versus
nurture and I think for a lot of us we
just assume nature versus nurture U that
the not being okay with cheating is
inherently just nature well in reality a
lot of it is nurtured is how our culture
shapes us oh you know we with
judeo-christian values here in the west
and so a lot of that comes from the
church and then is disseminated downward
through generation and generation Japan
is not a country that had judeo
Christian values for you know thousands
of years and a lot of other countries
who don't share that same you know
religious standpoint will not
necessarily have those same values now
does that mean it's all cultural of
course not there's perfectly reasonable
nature related reasons why women would
not want their Partners to cheat for
thousands of years it meant like you
know if they're sleeping with other
women and they have other kids then they
neglect your family and the family that
you've built with that man right and so
that's why those women spoke about one
thing what did they speak about don't go
have emotional connections don't go
leave in me for somebody else they don't
want their position threatened that's
the nature part that exists everywhere
where it's like yeah you know you might
be okay with prostitution right that's
the nurture the cultural aspect but
you're not okay with just full-on
cheating that because naturally you
don't want your place in that Dynamic to
be lost it's not even considered
cheating as a matter of fact because
there's no yeah emotion exactly they
they consider one acceptable and the
other one not and it makes sense why
like just it tracks on now is that
something you want to live by listen
everybody got to choose their culture
and their kind of values that they want
to set up but it does let you know that
just because you think it's normal where
you are doesn't mean it's normal where
everyone else is I don't know I think it
was really interesting just seeing how
open they are about it and how normal
place it is like prostitution over there
if you ask most people I think they
would probably say they don't think it's
cheating and it seems like for them it's
very culturally normal to say that
public like I didn't just watch what
they said I watch how they said it y'all
notice none of those women were hunched
they weren't looking left and right they
didn't even think it was nothing crazy
they were just like nah Japanese culture
is fine they said that [__] with the
chest yeah it was not even hiding it one
girl said I tell my boyfri you going to
use a prostitute she was giving him
advice shit's crazy and she was like yo
you better use them prostitute don't be
going with some random girl that's why I
think that [__] is normal it's not just
what they said it's how they said on a
public Street they were saying that [__]
recorded so many of them were saying it
openly without hesitation recorded so do
I think cheating is normal over there it
sounds like it from everything I've seen
now could be wrong there might be more
information um but yeah it definitely
seems like at least a prostitution
portion of it is very very normalized it
was interesting though yeah yeah can't
wait to go to
Japan you know what they say when in
Rome little boys when in
Japan little
horse know you
see you see you see that's a that's a no
that's no that's a no that's a no why
when in Rome with the boys oh that's
what they do in aent wrong as [__] up
as it is yeah okay but we now [__] yeah
just you know I can't go back in time I
don't want to I'm black I can't go back
in time uhhuh uhhuh so yeah we're not
[__] little boys yeah okay well like
Rome of that time doesn't even exist
anymore so that's fine okay but you know
what I
meant the time the saying comes from
Rome back in the day right right right
right right right so I was using it that
way the saying is When in Rome do like
the Romans it didn't no it says it went
in Rome little
boys the thing sorry I C that one on
eps's island they must have me up with
that Cod anyways uh
that's it for today's video Don't let us
know what you think in the comments cuz
they're going to be disabled